va revenir sur le triple meurtre qui a
été commis cette semaine à pointe aux
trembles et qui relance une fois plus le
débat sur les homicides conjugaux
comment expliquer la violence de la part
d'un conjoint
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour prévenir
ce genre de tragédies j'entends ce matin
avec comme thème des rosiers qui est
coordonnateur de l'organisme service d
aide aux conjoints de céder rosie
bonjour bonjour merci
arrivé tout juste d'une rencontre
d'ailleurs à québec un concernant une
coalition d'organismes âge pour les
hommes violents
exactement ça vous aide conjointe fait
partie d'un regroupement qui s'appelle
hackers daouki combien à peu près de
trente et un organisme qui travaille
auprès des amateurs de comportement
violent justement
on s'est rencontré pour un rencontre de
ces sept semaines et ça fait partie des
discussions je souhaite à notre régime
inévitablement à tous donc qu'est ce que
vous vous dites quand un drame comme
celui là survient parce que s'accumulent
mais il ya plusieurs choses qui ressort
un il ya vraiment un besoin de détendre
les ressources pour répondre à ce genre
de situation en ce moment ce qui se
passe c'est que la majorité des
organismes qui travaillent ou les
majorité des experts qui travaillent
auprès des hommes avec des comportements
violents sont saturés gérer la totalité
des organismes d'un choeur d'hommes et
ça vous avions conjoint également on
travaille à prendre à 110 pour ce qui
est difficile de capter ou de travailler
avec toutes les personnes les aider
n'importe quelle instance de violences
conjugales peu importe sa forme
l'eau c'est à peine que vos organismes
existants desrosiers
exactement c'est c'est quand même assez
triste comme situation
essentiellement nous on essaie d'avoir
une visibilité la plus grande possible
ce qui est souhaitable c'est qu'on a une
présence qui fait puis une notoriété qui
fait que beaucoup plus d'hommes de leur
propre chef viennent nous voir mais
également l'eau de favoriser la
collaboration avec les acteurs en sicile
alors c'est quoi les services que vous
pouvez faire quand vous dites on
voudrait que les hommes eux-mêmes fasse
appel à nos services qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez leur offrir pour les aider
concrètement en fait ça va c'est sûr ça
va dépendre de quel organisme de
services locaux en jeu d'ailleurs est
plus axé sur la prévention fait nous on
va faire des services de d'intervention
avec les hommes avec différentes
problématiques conjugue afin qu'on
accueille les hommes en difficultés
conjugales qui conçoit les comportements
violents qui sont qui sont qui suis la
violence ou qui sont en difficultés
conjugales et là une situation pourrait
kalliste de violences puis ont
scandalisé dépit diminuer le risque
harry l'autre chose c'est qu'on va
insérer des facteurs de provins
protection lorsqu'on est en prévention
pour s'assurer que il ya une diminution
de la possibilité que j'ai studio la
société commence concrètement mais
concrètement il ya eu beaucoup des
constructions qu'on doit faire on doit
centrer la personne sur elle même et
pourquoi elles ont des comportements de
contrôle pourquoi est ce qu'on va voir
certains types de comportements
il passait pas toutes les violences qui
sont illégales au criminel il ya des
comportements violents
on pense aux contrôles coercitif disons
la géolocalisation le suivi au jour des
messages textes pour s'assurer ou que
notre conjoint et qui sont une des
formes de violence mais qu'on doit
travailler dessus dépister les personnes
exactement ça en est un exemple de
l'harcèlement on est déjà dans la chaîne
du criminel c'est pas tout mais nous on
doit aussi faire un dépistage du risque
de dangerosité de ces personnes 9
lorsqu'ils viennent chez nous on les
visas portes avec de l'aide parce qu'on
veut qu'ils plus répondre à leurs
besoins répondent la source qu'il y mène
avec violent mais c'est toujours ce fait
d'un multi problématique de les gens
viennent pour avec un seul problème je
suis violent souvent beaucoup de choses
et je comprends mais quelqu'un pour
arriver et est dirigé j'ai des idées
noires j'ai des idées qui me traverse
l'esprit
je pourrais à la limite même commettre
un crime qu est ce que vous faites dans
ces moments il ya deux choses pas c'est
sûr que nous on le rencontre dans le
plus bref délai la majorité des
organismes tentent d'avoir une réponse
téléphonique rapide aussi possible
immédiate dans ce que l'on fait toujours
un dépistage du risque de dangerosité
soit le risque suicidaire ou omis cela
pour déterminer si la personne est à
risque pour elles mêmes ont un risque
pour autrui long d'une évaluation le ya
vraiment une liste de critères et de
flegme on veut étudier trois ans la
personne on doit le intervenir appelé la
police peut immédiatement sécurisé les
femmes les enfants les conjoints ou les
conjoints parce qu'on fait sans aigreur
à l'orientation sexuelle est ce que je
comprends assez qu' il faut davantage de
moyens pour pouvoir y arriver vraiment
absolument en ce moment grande échelle
oui parce qu'en ce moment le problème
est que la majorité des services qui
existent qui font du dépistage de sont
très limitées fait que beaucoup de
situations qui passent à travers les
filets du maillot d'ailleurs on demande
au ministre de santé services sociaux
depuis des années une augmentation
progressive de notre financement
idéalement pour avant l'ouverture totale
du québec on estime en quoi mais on
répond oui
malgré toutes les autres problématiques
sont épaulés seule chose mais on essaye
d'accentuer l'importance dans vos plus
de ressources l'importance de notre
expertise puis du dépistage systématique
à travers tout conclu un accord pour que
ma mère et on a vu donc l'adresse de
votre site internet
en bas de l'écran service aide conjointe
un.org lointaine desrosiers merci de me
voir merci beaucoup aussi